en bolivia todo está listo para la
posesión del nuevo presidente del país
luis arse y de su vicepresidente david
choquehuanca en las últimas horas han
arribado a bolivia diferentes
delegaciones del exterior entre ellas la
de españa que está presidida por el rey
felipe también están en bolivia tres
jefes de estado el presidente de
argentina alberto fernández el
presidente de paraguay mario abdo
benítez y el presidente de colombia iván
duque por otro lado han llegado hasta la
ciudad de la paz y se han parapetado en
los alrededores de la plaza murillo los
sectores sociales que apoyan al
movimiento al socialismo el partido
ganador de las elecciones porque quieren
garantizar la posesión de luisa se pues
en las últimas horas hubo anuncios de
los opositores de que harían protestas
en contra de los resultados de las
elecciones de hecho en las últimas horas
también hubo algunas manifestaciones en
diferentes departamentos del interior de
grupos opositores que denuncian fraude y
rechazan
los resultados de estas elecciones
se asume la presidencia con al menos dos
retos importantes
uno de ellos sacar al país de la
profunda crisis en la que se encuentra y
por otro lado reconciliar a los
bolivianos que han quedado profundamente
divididos después de un año de
confrontación por otro lado les informo
que mañana regresa a bolivia el ex
presidente evo morales- team ha
permanecido refugiado en argentina casi
un año